[Music]
how many of you communicate to your
friends using memes there are so many
memes out there they're perfect for any
scenario and any emotion and of course
there are those that just make us laugh
but how did that person on the picture
even become a meme in the first place
and how did that mean become popular
wait until you see what side-eyeing
chloe looks like now make sure you never
miss a video by subscribing to our
channel give this video a big thumbs up
if you love memes now join us as we
discuss the real stories behind ten
popular internet memes
Kermit but that's none of my business
when this particular meme is used you
know someone just gave a strong most
likely sarcastic opinion about something
but how did Kermit from the Muppets make
it and became internet famous all over
again the year to remember is 2014 when
Kermit memes were mostly shared on
Instagram a couple of months later and
official that's none of my business
Instagram accounts started and it
quickly gained an impressive number of
followers at the same time the account
launched Twitter users started using
that's none of my business hashtag and
the post received tens of thousands of
mentions then a tumblr blog was made and
it highlighted some of the best memes
people posted on Twitter and Instagram
one of them was the one where Kermit
drinks tea two years later the image
resurfaced again in an Instagram post
from LeBron James who was wearing the
tea drinking Kermit on his hat the image
was picked up by many news sources
including Good Morning America who
called the meme the tea lizard they got
corrected by many meme fans who use the
opportunity to continue the Kermit meme
cache me outside meme cache me outside
is one of the most popular memes of 2017
and it all started with an episode of a
dr. Phil show but how did a 13 year old
girl's behavior managed to grab the
attention of the entire world and turned
her into an Internet personality let's
find out on September 15th 2016 a clip
was uploaded online showing the 13-year
old Danielle bergalis outrageous
behavior including stealing a car
the audience was stunned and didn't
approve of her attitude which made
Danielle angry she called them out for a
confrontation saying cache me outside
how about that because of her accent and
her attitude the phrase instantly went
viral the mean began spreading through
the wee
and caught everyone's attention when it
was posted on a Facebook page called
digital memes interestingly enough
Danielle also made it onto a reddit
subreddit called Mandela effect many
pointed out they were surprised to hear
this episode only aired now since they
claimed they saw her in an episode years
ago it was later confirmed that the
episode didn't air until September 2016
but all this talk made Danielle become
one of the most popular teenagers on the
Internet Danielle appeared in music
videos and promo shoots and had
sponsorship deals
according to elite daily Danielle could
become a millionaire by the end of 2017
ridiculously photogenic guy this proves
it anyone can become a meme and it can
happen just about anywhere at any time
it can happen in your childhood at the
beach at a talk show in a restaurant you
name it but there's a meme out there
that shows a guy who's so photogenic he
even looked good when running a marathon
check out this picture most were
sweating and taking deep breaths as they
were running but this guy seemed
completely chill and he looked good
doing it too it is definitely a
well-earned mean name in our opinion the
guy's name is Eddie little and he was
running the 2012 Cooper River bridge run
this photo became popular after the
photographer of the event uploaded the
picture on Reddit and noticed that this
man was very good-looking the Internet
of course took it a little further and
photoshopped his face on everyone who's
running in that race his picture was
then posted on Mashable MSN and quick
meme waters Eddie's thoughts on being a
meme he claimed that he feels honored to
be a part of a huge online joke what's
your favorite ridiculously photogenic
guy meme Ariza's runs marathon and wins
my heart
Harambee Harambee guerilla became the
meme of 2016 but it is also one of the
most controversial memes of all time if
you're not familiar with the incident
the 17 year old gorilla belonged to the
Cincinnati Zoo but lost his life on May
28 2016 when a four year old boy fell
into the enclosure after the gorilla got
ahold of the child and carried him
across the water the zoo staff had to
quickly step in as a result Harambee
lost his life the controversial video of
the incident gathered the attention of
the entire world soon a petition that
called for justice for Harambee started
many claim there was absolutely no need
to end a life of a gorilla
in such a case and others argued it was
the only way to protect the boy
it was Twitter that turned Harambee into
a meme after many tributes circulated
online and it soon spread into
inappropriate jokes unfortunately many
claimed this meme is done in poor taste
including the Cincinnati Zoo the
spokesperson of the zoo released a
statement saying that they are not
amused by the memes and it should all
come to an end what do you think is this
the mean that went just a little bit too
far
Rach comics we bet at least one of your
friends uses this meme on a daily basis
you know those drawings of faces showing
a range of emotions they're usually
referred to as rage faces and are
created in very simple drawing programs
most of the time they are drawn as
regular stick figures telling the story
in a very simple comic format the meme
usually ends up in a joke or an
unexpected punchline people also
normally use this meme when they are
expressing their anger over a real-life
event that happened to them during the
day this meme dates back to 2008 and it
was introduced on 4chan which frequently
popularizes a variety of images in 2009
these rage faces carried on over to
Reddit where the community launched a
subreddit that was all about rage comics
after a while more and more characters
appeared did you know that these rage
comics were used as a teaching tool in
2011 an English instructor introduced
these characters for his Japanese
students who were learning English he
said that their expressions showed a
universal variety of emotions that were
easily translatable into different
languages who would have thought that a
meme could hold an educational value
which one of the rage comic characters
is your favorite ours is the me gusta
character if you know what I mean pop
quiz time which meme is usually used to
express a desire for some frisky
business is it a cash me outside be
overly attached girlfriend or see if you
know what I mean we'll let you think
about this for a moment if you've
guessed if you know what I mean you get
1,000 points the meme showed mr. bean
looking at something with slightly
raised eyebrows this meme started in
2012 on 9gag when a user posted let's
watch a movie if you know what I mean
and used a screen capture of row and
Atkinson in mr. bean on the same day
another user added a vectorized version
of the photo and wrote if you know what
I mean on the picture
this to the end of any sentence can end
up having a completely different
intention if you know what we mean this
sentence was used by comedians who
wanted to make sure the audience got the
inside joke it was used similarly to
that's what she said the meme has also
been posted on all notable meme sites
and it received a good number of likes
and attention the memes popularity has
slowed down but we bet it still just as
used as the saying that's what she said
first world problems you've seen this
meme right it's an extreme closeup of a
woman in distress with tears coming down
her cheeks
you wouldn't think anything of this
picture right but in the world of means
this calls for an opportunity to turn
this image internet famous and title it
first world problems
you know those problems that we think
are so big when in reality they aren't
very important in the large scale of
things so who's the lady behind the
first world problems meme her name is
Sylvia Bettina and she's actually an
Italian model it's unclear what she
thinks of being a meme as she never
released any official statements but we
can imagine she's particularly thrilled
but she's not the only one whose image
is used to showcase the perspective of
our problems her first world problems
meme also extended to Dawson creeks
james van der beek
who seems to be representing the 1990s
version of the first world problems you
can find plenty of differently themed
first world problems memes who would
have thought that a meme would sometimes
allow us to see a joke in our problems
and put them in perspective Doge meme
Fame has no limits children celebrities
fashion models and even animals everyone
can become meme famous and it can happen
at any time
take Doge for example this dog is just a
regular Shiba Inu belonging to a
Japanese kindergarten teacher who posted
photos of her rescue dog on her blog in
2010 those photos included her dog
glaring sideways with raised eyebrows
its expression was so interesting it got
posted to Reddit where a user misspelled
the word dog and added an e this
particular misuse of the word was first
noted in 2005 in Homestar runners puppet
show where home star wrongly spells out
dog the popularity of the Shiba Inu
picture started growing and with it came
many websites in 2013 a Bitcoin talk
forum member created the Doge
cryptocurrency and posted a thread
dogecoin very currency many coins Wow
v 1.1 released while this was a
sarcastic response to bitcoins currency
changes the phrases from that title
captured the Internet's attention
shortly after images of the Shiba Inu
started appearing again with tons of
phrases using adverbs very and many and
then ending with Wow and that's how the
Doge meme was created stoner Stanley
also known as the really high guy you
probably noticed that many mean names
come with the same first letter in the
first and last name we're not quite sure
why this is but it seems to work meet
Stanley the photo usually shows a young
man who looks like he's under the
influence of illicit substances the meme
is popular with a subreddit called trees
this memes name also comes with the
number 10 which this subreddit uses to
showcase the level of intoxication so
how did Stanley end up as a popular meme
after the image got posted on reddit in
2011 another editor created a quick meme
page a couple of months later several
versions of the meme were posted to
various other forums as well as BuzzFeed
and tumblr the memes text usually
features hilarious actions or questions
that are usually asked by people under
the influence not much else is known
about Stanley and we don't know who the
man in the picture actually is we just
hope he's okay with being a slightly
negative meme and that this hasn't hurt
his professional reputation if you
became a meme how would you explain this
in a future job interview side-eyeing
chloe child memes are just as popular as
the baby on your vanna's never mind
album do you remember the cute little
girl whose parents gave her an amazing
surprise they took her to Disneyland for
three days and she didn't find out until
they were already in the car but then
the camera shifted to her sister Chloe
who was not so impressed by her sister's
reaction the video itself was absolutely
hilarious but Chloe became the spirit
animal of many and her attitude earned
her a spot in the most popular memes
category her reaction quickly became
popular on tumblr when a user uploaded a
[ __ ] of chloe and her sister Lily it soon
went viral you can find side-eye and
chloe everywhere usually the captions
come with plenty of attitude and
relatable events like
having this reaction when a teacher
calls your name when you weren't even
looking in their direction this meme
dates back to 2013 when Chloe was just
two years old and here's what she looks
like in 2016 we do wonder does she still
do the side-eye or she a bit more
excited about Disneyland these days the
family still uploads videos so who knows
maybe they'll recreate the famous
Disneyland surprise clip what's your
favorite meme of all time let us know in
the comments below don't forget to
subscribe to our Channel you've just
watched far too of the real story behind
ten popular internet memes click here
for part one see you in the next video
[Music]